[Musica]
una sera a tutti allora quelle che avete
visto scorrere e che vedete proiettato
in qua sopra evidentemente sono immagini
del deserto come era prevedibile che
fosse visto il tema e per la precisione
sono particolari del deserto del sahara
che come tutti sappiamo è la più grande
superficie desertica del nostro pianeta
queste immagini sono alla base di un
progetto folle inutile al tempo stesso e
che ho iniziato circa due anni fa nel
2013 più o meno di questo periodo è che
almeno nelle intenzioni dovrebbe
completarsi tra 50 anni lo specifico è
poi vi spiegherò perché un archivio
digitale
il titolo in italiano è traducibile più
o meno con un calmo fallimento del
deserto e siccome però sono una persona
come dire che gli piace partire da
lontano quando affronta gli argomenti
se avrete la pazienza di ascoltarmi
proverò a raccontare cosa tiene assieme
queste immagini satellitari il deserto e
il concetto di fallimento che forse è
l'aspetto più importante
dunque il tema alla base non è tanto il
deserto nella sua forma materiale qui si
parla di bit e nello specifico il tema
di cui parlerò oggi è quello della
memoria collettiva e della sua
trasmissione
l'avvento diciamo di quei dispositivi
che tutti teniamo nelle tasche o sulla
scrivania di casa ovvero i computer
dunque le tecnologie digitali quindi
l'avvento di tecnologie di archiviazione
unito alla nascita di internet e alla
sua diffusione capillare hanno di fatto
gettato le basi di una nuova società
dell'informazione che pone la
comunicazione come valore fondante
oggi siamo in grado di comunicare in
tempo reale con ogni parte del mondo e
abbiamo finito con lo spostare molte
delle attività
diciamo del nostro quotidiano
all'interno della sfera il materiale
della rete l'esempio che faccio sempre
quello dei social network per cui
abbiamo spostato la dimensione della
relazione tra le persone all'interno
della sfera immateriale e digitale ma
non è solo quella come dicevo prima
molte molti aspetti del nostro
quotidiano e sono stati fagocitati dalla
rete e da questo mondo digitale che
almeno nelle intenzioni di chi questa
tecnologia cep la vende dovrebbe essere
la tecnologia definitiva non ha
degradazione diciamo di qualità e che
quindi dovrebbe garantire per qualche
strano motivo l'eternità e quindi oggi
riversiamo in questi archivi invisibili
perché noi non sappiamo dove stanno
riversiamo tutte le nostre memorie
individuali siano esse fotografie siano
essi documenti e così come andiamo a
depositare le nostre memorie individuali
lo stiamo facendo come cultura
collettiva come società
ora qualcuno potrebbe prendervi per il
nudista di turno e per questo motivo mi
sono preparato e vi riporto come dire il
pensiero di uno dei fondatori di
internet kevin surf vinton
per la precisione l'inter e amici surf
ci mette in guardia perché recentemente
ha sostenuto che il digitale rischia di
trasformare il secolo che stiamo vivendo
in un nuovo medioevo digitale
cosa si intende si intende un era
inaccessibile
c'è un epoca inaccessibile alle epoche
successive questo perché c'erano tutti
raccontato che il digitale dovrebbe
risolvere tutti i nostri problemi ma il
problema è che la nostra società e la
società diciamo fondata sull'economia
del digitale e sulla tecnologia digitale
a una velocità aggiorna sviluppa innova
i suoi prodotti tecnologici a una
velocità tale che i documenti e le
immagini salvati con le tecnologie più
vecchie diventano sempre più
inaccessibili ad esempio che faccio
sempre è quello dei vhs che a memoria
sa che è diventato sempre più difficile
poi riportare quella memoria di filmini
familiari piuttosto che film riportarli
sulla nuova nuovo sistema digitale e
quindi alla base di tutto questo c'è un
una strategia che è la strategia che
tiene in piedi poi le
le the company's che quella
dell'obsolescenza programmata che ci
spinge a comprare sempre l'ultimo
modello di tecnologia e questa velocità
di sviluppo che è dettata da ragioni
prettamente economiche di fatto non va
di pari sviluppo con la velocità di
preservazione dei contenuti che noi
stiamo generando e depositando
all'interno diciamo delle tecnologie
digitali
questo per dirvi che il problema più
serio di quanto non si immagini e
ritornare a vinton surf vi dico quale è
stato il suo suggerimento il suo
suggerimento è avete delle foto di
famiglia da conservare a vedere i
documenti stampate le non stiamo
parlando di uno qualunque ripeto stiamo
parlando del padre uno dei padri diciamo
dell'inter di come lo conosciamo adesso
come a dire che il supporto cartaceo che
tanti oggi stanno un pochino denigrando
ha un suo perché il super che di
trasmissione di memoria per le future
generazioni
quindi fatta questa precisazione torno
al lavoro di cui io ho fatto vedere un
estratto che nasce dalla riflessione
analoghe a quelle di winton surf tra
l'altro per una curiosa coincidenza lo
stesso vinton cerf nelle sue
affermazioni utilizza il termine deserto
digitale poco per descrivere questa
situazione il progetto nasce come una
performance di cui conoscete tutti
il significato ed è una performance però
non sviluppata da un corpo umano ma da
un algoritmo ovvero nasce come il lavoro
ottenuto dalle dalle operazioni di
calcolo di un algoritmo
l'obiettivo di questo algoritmo è come
dicevo prima tanto folle quanto inutile
ovvero sfrutta il grande database di
google delle mappe di google che tutti
voi conoscete
recupera se realmente le immagini
satellitari del deserto e va a
indicizzare queste immagini in un
archivio digitale
spesso non si sa dove
sulla rete quindi di fatto è
un'operazione diciamo seriale ripetitiva
che consiste nell'archiviare il deserto
del sahara in un archivio digitale è un
progetto che chiaramente voi conoscete
tutti sarà abbastanza ampio e vasto e
richiede del tempo come dicevo prima
richiedere a 50 anni per essere
completata abbiamo iniziato nel 2013
e se come dire le previsioni sono giuste
nel 2060 3 questo archivio si completerà
quindi questa operazione e ripetitiva
dall'algoritmo di fatto trasforma
l'algoritmo in un'entità che attraversa
di fatto il deserto lo attraversa
chiaramente nella sua forma il materiale
digitale ma questo è quello che fa e
qualcuno in genere quando vado a
raccontare questo progetto mi dice sì ma
perché non hai scelto il mare perché non
hai scelto le città e il la motivazione
prettamente simbolica il deserto come
hanno raccontato altre persone qua è un
simbolo di fatto innanzitutto il deserto
è un luogo inospitale inospitale per la
vita soprattutto per la vita dell'essere
umano
il deserto è il luogo dove profeti e
bisogna visionari di ogni sorta si
perdono di tanto in tanto alla ricerca
delle grandi rivelazioni il deserto e
infine un passaggio un paesaggio in
eterno mutamento in cui ogni traccia
dell'uomo tende a svanire nel volgere di
poco tempo e questo ci porta a
riflettere
sul tema del fallimento perché qualcuno
direbbe caspita 50 anni una impresa
monumentale titanica
in realtà io ho poche speranze che
questo attraversamento possa riuscire
non per le mie poche capacità o per la
potenza di calcolo o quant'altro ma
proprio per quello che dicevo prima
siamo troppo ottimisti nel guardare a
tecnologia di cui cir con circondiamo
oggi la tecnologia come affermano viene
in mente virilio diciamo implica sempre
il fallimento l'incidente quando noi
abbiamo inventato come direbbe virilio
quando noi abbiamo inventato il battello
abbiamo inventato il naufragio
quando abbiamo inventato il treno
abbiamo inventato l'incidente
ferroviario
ecco perché alla fine il fallimento è
forse il fine ultimo di questa
performance non mi interessa arrivare in
fondo e 50 anni ma mi interessa mi
interessa
sono certo che fallirà ma trovo che sia
interessante perché porterà a nudo
quella che è un problema che ci
troveremo ad affrontare presto ovvero la
preservazione della memoria collettiva
perché dovrebbe fallire è molto semplice
chiunque abbia avuto a che fare con con
la tecnologia web sa benissimo che
nell'arco di anche solo un anno i
linguaggi le tecnologie cambiano a una
velocità spaventosa e davvero pensiamo
che fra 50 anni internet esisterà nella
forma in cui l'abbiamo oggi esisterà
ancora quello che oggi chiamiamo google
map e
la tecnologia server che ospita il mio
algoritmo chiamiamolo così esisterà
ancora la domanda non lo so per cui per
concludere ribadisco un po il concetto
che è il concetto di fondo del progetto
che abbiate pazienza non abbiate fretta
perché il deserto sta arrivando
grazie
[Musica]